p 4 p 主
日常の食事は
私達の体が健やかに生きるために必要な栄養素を体に届けるという役割をしています
自分が特別に好きなわけじゃなかったはずなのに
口にしたときにああこれ食べたかった
カラダの中からエネルギーが溢れてきたという経験はありませんか
私は気がつきました
日常の食事
毎日これだけ何回も訪れて食べて経験しているのに言葉がないということにです
にスタバへという言葉があってアデナ食事
綺麗な食事は写真にとってこれが美味しかった
楽しかったって話されるんですけれども
一方で一条の普段の食事特に映画てぃぶな感情や経験
こういうことは話されることがないんですね
それゆえにその食事の健康や食事に対する不満とか不安を
話す
機械も関係もないというそこに大きな課題があるということに気がつきました
私がこの活動するきっかけになったのが社員食堂という言葉です
私2007年から7年間
7000人のいろんな国籍の社員が集まる
カチャ員食堂の入れ来たをしていました
この二くん間に
支社の社員食堂作りに来たこともあります
それを始めた頃に
ここ俺空にしたいっていう声を聞いたんです
その時にえレストランじゃないって心の中から強く否定の気持ちが湧き上がってきたん
ですけど
じゃあなんなの
という答えが出ないままでいました
そしてその会社を辞めて
2016年の春にご縁があって
日本橋大伝馬町にある社員食堂ラボというところのイレクターをすることになりました
社員食堂ラボ
普通社員食堂といったら
会社の中にあって
いそこで働いている社員の人たちが集まってくる場所だと思いますよね
でもここはちょっと違うのですクリエイターの人たちが集まってきてそして
スコアシェアキッチンなんですね
菜食堂って何だろう
もう1回考える機会が訪れたんですね
それでいっか
考えて考えてやっと出てきた答えが
社員を働く人
食堂を日常の食それをラボする場所
それが社員食堂等もなんだって思った時に今まで長く持っていた謎の塊がスーッと溶け
ていくそんな実感を得ました
そして働く人たちの日常の食事のかだがいっぱいあるって事にもその時に気がついたん
です
食事って昔はお腹いっぱい食べてとにかくカロリーを手に入れることそれが目的でした
でも今の現代の都市の課題は違います
食べる目的私2つあると思っています
一つはまず心が生きるため
美味しくて嬉しいお腹いっぱいで幸せと言ったことですね
ここは s と卵が担当する領域だと思っています
そして2つ目2つ目が体が生きること
私たち生き物ですから生き物として体が健やかに生きるために必要な栄養素をちゃんと
バランスよく摂れることをこれが体が生きるためです
これが食堂が担当するんだというふうに思ったんです
そして
なぜ働く人なのかというと
働いている人
特に
外食で食事を賄おうとしている人っていうのはなかなか食事が太平
年は美味しいもので溢れています
だけどだいたい炭水化物タンパク質そして揚げ物そういうものはいっぱいあるんです
けれども
一方でそれとバランスをとって必要なビタミン無機質
フレに必要なのが野菜たっぷりの野菜
それに芋豆果物といったものなんですけれどもそれがなかなか取れない
本当にここが大変です
食堂や外食の食堂やレストランというのはこのバランスは自分で撮ってねという前提で
だいたい
構成されています
でこの自分で撮ってね昔はおかあさんや奥さんが家の中で一生懸命考えて用意して
くださってたんですけれども今はなかなかそういう人がいないんです
なぜなら単身者が多い
そして女の人も働いているなかなかご飯が作れない
そして賃貸のマンションはどんどんキッチンが小さくなっていてなかなかちゃんとご飯
を作る
そういうところになっていないんですね
そして働いていると毎日忙しい
今日はお昼ごはんはカップ麺とおにぎりで済ませちゃったとか
夜食べ損なってスナック菓子食べて寝ちゃったみたいなことがあってそれがたまたま
ならいいんですけれども
前に続いている
そうするとああこれで大丈夫かな
こんなんじゃ病気にならないかな
手マンや不満があるんですね
だけどなかなかそれが話す機会がないから
その問題が解決されないんですだから働く人の日常の食にはいろんな
解決されないテーマがあるというふうに気がついたんです
そこで
チャイ熟度ラボで始まったのが大人食どこ
という活動です
この大人食堂話す作る食べるの3つの3部構成からなっています
さて皆さん今日会場の外にホワイトボードでちょっと聞きしているんですけれども話す
作る食べるの3つのうち自分が一番大事だなと思うのはどれですか
1つ選んで今私きますので教えてください
いいですかじゃあまず話す
-1
少ししてが分かりましたねありがとうございます
はいじゃあ作る-1
貼ってきましたねありがとうございます
ラベル-1
はいっぱいありましたねはいありがとうございますやっぱりみんな食べる好きですね
牛ですもんね
はい今ですね今を伺った質問は一つの答えではありません
今聞かれて自分がどれかなーって思った選んだ一つそれが正解ですチョコを大事にして
ください
大人食堂な話すは
日常の食事の中でもどちらかというと言ったら恥ずかしいなぁとかちょっとやだなー
みたいな
ネガティブなことを話してもらうってことを大事にしているしています
ソーシャルメディアだと切り離した話であふれているんですけれども話してもらうのは
ご飯作りたくないとか
もう野菜嫌いとかあとはポテチいっぱい食べちゃうみたいな話をしてもらいます
それをちょっと恥ずかしいでも行ってみる自分の声と言葉でそうすると自分の耳が効く
んです
あれあれ
キライって言ったけど何が嫌いなんだっけとか
それ食べたかったんだっけ
食べて満足したかなというふうに頭が働き出すんです
ここで大事なのは正解を得ることではないんです
自分の中から出てきた
言葉を取り出してそしてそこで確かめること
ただそれだけです
鳥が話す
大人食堂の作るはお料理をするというプロセスよりもまずは素材素材に乗っている生産
者さんと生産地
そして食べる人の体調のことをつないでいく
そこを考えるということを大事にしています
お店食堂では
参加者に食べてある野菜を持ってきてくださいという風にお願いしています
そうするといろんな
素材のストーリーが集まってくるんです
近所の八百屋さんの
地元の名前がついたトマトですとか
ちーさん者さんの中の畑で爆発しそうだったキャベツを送ってもらいました
とか
かあさんが実家で作ってくれた
育ちすぎた小屋です
そんな感じでいろんなストーリーが集まってきます
さらに
今日はちょっと苦いもの食べたかったんですよ
行ったり良い香りが欲しかったんですって言って自分の体調と相談した素材ラミの話を
してくださる方もいます
そんな風に素材を通していろんな人々や風景が繋がっているということを知ってもらい
たいんですね
お料理作るのプロセスの中というのは自分の
人間としての五感を一番フル稼働させる時間です
今日は大工を持ってきました
これは糸島の大根なんですけれども大根の葉っぱ
ざっくり切ってでトントントンって包丁で切る時の募り
リズムの良さと完食
化合パッときって言って所も実にする
そうすると現場の光が反射してキラキラってかがよくんですね
ことが料理をすると炒めたり茹でたりしたときに出てくる
弓削それの香りと温度
胸の奥まで吸って吸いたくなります
そんなプロセス後は食べる人が口の中に入った時のことを想像してみる
今日はがりって食べたいなぁと思ったら大きく切って
もし小さいお子さんがいたらじゃあちょっと食べやすいようにというふうに小さく切っ
たる
という風に
この中にいろんな気遣いがあるんです
そういうことの一つ一つ
食事を形作っているエネルギーというのを食べる人に渡していただきたいんです
私はこれからの日常の食はみんなが作らなくてもいいと思っています
そして前にて作らなくてもいい
でもその代わりこういうふうに食事に込められたメッセージを
渡す受け取るということがとても大切になってくると思っています
食べる人に話してそのエネルギーを伝えてほしいのです
いい時ばかりではありませんが作るの中で知ったこと発見や経験や工夫
それを話して伝えることでいろんな人や場所とつながり
体が支えられているということを食べる人にしていうキッカケを作って頂きたいのです
次に大人食堂の食べるあっ
たっぷりの野菜料理を好きなだけ心ゆくまで食べてもいいよというアクティビティです
先日食べてもらったら一人で1キロ度去った人がいました
火が通ってない生野菜のサラダではない
火が通った野菜をお腹いっぱい食べてもいいというシチュエーションは意外とないん
です
そこで皆そのたくさんの野菜料理を目の前にすると体から
わぁ食べたいというエネルギーがあふれ出てくるのいつも私は感じます
食べてみて心地が良いかどうか体調が変わるかどうか
皆さんも食事の中でご自身のからば喜ぶ実感
それを観察してみてください
こんな風に日常の食を軸にして考えると自分の体は何が欲しいのかなあということと
この自分の身体が生きることを支えてくれている人々のエネルギーを気がつくきっかけ
になります
ご自身の体が呼吸が深く入って体に力が入る
それが答えです
あもしかしたらあの時のことかなって思い出せる経験はありませんか
ぜひ身近な方と日常の食事の想い発見を交わす時間を持ってみてください
そこからが皆さんそれぞれのうとな食堂の始まりです
[拍手]